in the last video we learned that
380,000 years after the Big Bang which
is still roughly 13.7 billion years ago
every point I shouldn't say every point
every atom in space that was kind of at
this roughly 3,000 Kelvin temperature
was emitting was emitting this
electromagnetic radiation since every
point in space was they were point in
space or there was points in the
universe then that radiation is only
just now reaching us it has been
traveling for 13.7 billion years so when
we look at radiation that's been
traveling for that long we can look in
any to any direction and we'll see this
uniform radiation in that uniform and
that radiation has been redshifted into
the microwave range from the higher
frequencies that it was actually emitted
at now a question that might pop in your
brain is well what happens if we wait a
billion years because if we wait a
billion years if we have a billion three
a billion 380,000 years after the
beginning of the universe this stuff
won't just be atoms anymore it will have
can starting to condense into actual
stars we would not with the universe at
this point in space at every point in
space will no longer be this uniform
will actually start having condensation
into stars so if we go the universe if
we move forward a little bit the
universe will expand maybe I'll just
draw half of it since its expanded its
obviously expanding much more but now
all of a sudden we actually have stars
these aren't these are no longer just
uniform atoms spread through the
universe we actually have condensation
into stars and so if you look at what is
being emitted from the points in space
from which we're only now getting this
cosmic background radiation if we wait a
billion years what the light that we see
from those points in space will not look
like this uniform radiation it'll start
to look a little bit more like the more
mature parts of the universe it'll start
to will essentially be looking at the
universe a billion years after the Big
Bang when stars have formed other
structures of form so the question is in
a billion years will this cosmic
microwave background radiation disappear
and I'm using the billion just because
that
you know just just arbitrarily use a
number but will it eventually disappear
and there's kind of the answer to that
is yes and no so to think about it it is
true that this point in space will
mature it will mature in a billion years
it won't it will no longer be this
uniform
I guess this uniform haze of hot
hydrogen atoms but we have to think
about is there were further points in
the universe there were further points
in the universe at that same time there
were further points that were also
emitting this that were also emitting
this radiation and the original photons
from those original points still haven't
gotten to us so from those further out
points right now the observable universe
is we can only see light we can only see
electromagnetic radiation that's been
traveling for 13.7 billion years and
another billion years the universe will
be a billion years older and then there
will be radiation that has been
traveling for fourteen point seven
billion years and so we will start to
observe that and we'll start to observe
that radiation from the same time period
in the universe it'll just be from
further out now what I want to make
clear is is that since that since those
points were even further out where that
radiation was emitted the stuff that
we'll see in a billion years it will be
even more redshifted even even more even
more redshifted so at that point the
cosmic background radiation we see will
will have longer wavelengths than the
radio spectrum it will be redder and I
should say redder because we're already
we're already more would rather have two
DS under a written redder well it would
be it would be more red than then the
microwave radiation and of course that's
that's a funny thing because microwave
radiation is already more red than
actual visible red light it has a longer
wavelength now this will keep happening
and I don't know and what you know it'll
it'll keep happening we'll keep getting
radiation as we go further and further
into the future we'll keep getting
radiation from further out points in
space and it'll get more and more
redshifted
the actual wavelengths of that
electromagnetic light will be bigger and
bigger and bigger
until we really aren't able to even see
as electromagnetic light because it'll
be redshifted to infinity it'll have an
infinite it'll have an infinite
wavelength and to make that point clear
I want to show you that there will even
be points at some point there'll be kind
of a threshold where we can't even get
radiation from further out and let me
show you let me draw a diagram of that
so let's say that this is the universe
let's say that this is the universe 13.7
billion years ago right with that
radiation what we now see is cosmic
microwave background radiation right
when it started to be emitted and let's
say that this is the point in the
universe where we are now so this is us
let's say let's say that this is the
point in the universe that where we now
observe the background ray she or this
is one of the points we obviously could
form a circle around us it could be any
of these points over here we're only we
that where the the photons the
electromagnetic radiation that were
emitted from this point 380,000 years
after the beginning of the universe is
only just now reaching us so this this
is the point in the universe where from
which we are observing the cosmic
background radiation and let me be very
clear that point in the universe has now
matured into things that look you know
into stars and galaxies and planets and
if they were to look at our point in
space they are also going to see cosmic
background radiation from us it's not
like this is some type of permanently
old place it's just the light we're
getting from them right now is old light
light that they at that point in space
emitted way before it was able to mature
into actual structures so this is this
is this is the point in space from which
we are receiving from which we were
receiving cosmic background radiation
right now I don't want to write all that
it will take me forever now let's take
another point in space that's whatever
this distance is we it's what's actually
estimated to be about now it's estimated
to be about 46 billion light years at
that time when things were just
beginning to it be emitted this was only
about 36 million light years so this was
a base and and this is a very rough
estimate I shouldn't even write it down
because that's really based on how fast
we assume the universe is expanding and
all of that type of things but it was
just a lot smaller than
46 billion light years now let's to go
that same distance again from this point
in space so once they let me make it
clear this is 380,000 years ago 380,000
years ago now let's fast forward let's
fast forward
sorry not 380,000 years ago 380,000
years after the Big Bang after the Big
Bang which is approximately it's still
13.7 billion years ago so that's then
now let's look at now and now I'll just
draw it a little bit bigger it's
actually going to be much much bigger
now now if we do it a little bit bigger
so when I draw it like this this is
where we are now this point in space is
this point in space from which we are
only now receiving that cosmic
background radiation is over here and
then this other point in space is going
to be over here and we saw in the video
on the actual size of the observable
universe not just what it appears to be
based on the how long the lights been
traveling this is now on the order of 46
or 47 billion light years 46 billion
light years and so this distance is also
going to be 46 billion light years 46
billion
46 billion light years now every point
in space back then was emitting this was
emitting this radiation we have this
uniform radiation it was just hydrogen
atoms everywhere these hot hydrogen
atoms now we are only maybe I should
just do it in the color of the radiation
so this guy's receiving I'm just showing
it's coming from this guy we're only now
13.7 billion years in the future
receiving photons from this guy only now
are we receiving it and frankly this
green guy only now is going to be
receiving photons when he looks at the
points in space or the things that he
thinks are the points base out there he
will see that uniform he will see that
uniform radiation and likewise this guy
over here will only now be receiving
photons from the point in space for
where we are now he'll see the universe
where we are now as it was 380,000 years
after the Big Bang and same thing from
that point in space the photons will
only just now reach now let's think
about it it took this guy's photons
it took this guy's photons let me make
it clear
it took him 13.7 billion years to reach
this point over here which is now 46
billion light years away from us and the
universe continues to expand it's
depending on the if the universe expands
fast enough there's no way there's no
way that that photon that got to this
guy will eventually get to this the
universe is expanding faster than the
light can never even catch up to us and
this light will never ever ever get to
us and so there is some threshold some
distance from which we will never get
light and during this time period or
actually from from which we will never
ever get any electromagnetic radiation
so the simple answer is the cosmic
background radiation from this or the
cosmic background radiation from this
point yes it will start to mature we
won't be as uniform if we go fast
forward 400 million years or a billion
years but we will get uniform radiation
from further out but it'll be even more
redshifted and the further forward we
get into the future the background
radiation we get will be from further
and further out and it will be more and
more and more redshifted until some
point where it's going to be so red
shifted that we won't even observe it as
electromagnetic radiation and there's
some threshold where we won't even
observe anything anymore because beyond
that the light wasn't able to actually
get to us